hi everyone
this is professor m.science and today i
want to discuss the concept of quantum
measurement
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics the question we asked
today is very simple
if we want to measure a physical
property of a particle for example its
position
what does quantum mechanics tell us
about the possible outcomes of this
measurement
put it another way can we predict what
the position of the particle will be
when we measure it the answer to this
question is by no means trivial
and it introduces the famous
probabilistic nature of quantum
mechanics
it is impossible to predict the outcome
of a quantum measurement
all we can predict is its likelihood
this statement has profound implications
but is very often misunderstood so in
this video we'll explore it in some
detail
there is a companion video that goes
deeper into the mathematical subtleties
of measurements in quantum mechanics so
i encourage you to check it out in the
description
let's go in this video we discuss what
happens in quantum mechanics when we
measure
a physical quantity the quantity could
be for example the position of a
particle
or its momentum or its energy but to
keep the discussion general we're simply
going to call this physical quantity
a we know from postulate 2 of quantum
mechanics
that such a physical quantity is
associated with a hermitian operator
a that is called an observable to
understand what it means to measure a
in quantum mechanics the key equation we
need to consider is the
eigenvalue equation of the operator a
here
in this equation lambda n are the
eigenvalues
and u n are the eigenstates
if the names eigenvalues and eigenstates
don't sound familiar to you
then you should first check the video on
eigenvalues and eigenstates that you can
find link in the description because in
this video i will assume that you know
what they are and you also know how to
calculate them for any operator a
as we know from the video on eigenvalues
and eigenstates
postulate 3 of quantum mechanics tells
us that the result of a measurement of a
physical quantity
is one of the eigenvalues of the
associated observable
what this means is that when we want to
measure property a
we first need to solve the corresponding
eigenvalue equation up here
and this allows us to find all
eigenvalues which we can write as lambda
1
lambda 2 lambda 3 and so on
postulator 3 tells us that whatever
state our system is in
when we measure a we can only get one of
these eigenvalues as the outcome of the
measurement
so the operator a encodes all the
possible outcomes of the measurement
irrespective of what the state of the
system is
the key question becomes if we measure a
in a system in state
psi which eigenvalue will we get
postular 3 tells us that we will get one
of the lambdas but it doesn't tell us
which one
for this we need to look at the next
postulate
postulate 4 tells us what value we get
when we measure a in a system in state
psi it tells us that we will get
specific eigenvalue lambda
n with probability p given by the
absolute value squared of the bracket
between the associated eigen state u n
and the state psi of the system so what
does this mean
we've already discussed that for
operator a we have a list of eigenvalues
lambda 1
lambda 2 lambda 3 and so on each of
these eigenvalues corresponds to an
eigenstate
u1 u2 u3 and so on
and these two lists are always the same
for operator a
and they are independent of the state of
our system they simply come from the
eigenvalue equation of the operator
but when we measure a we measure it in a
system in a specific state
psi what postular 4 tells us then is the
following
we will get lambda 1 with probability
given by the absolute value squared of
u1 psi
we will get lambda 2 with probability
given by the absolute value squared of
u2
psi and so on
so what we actually get when we measure
a depends on two things
first what we get depends on the
intrinsic properties of a
its eigenvalues and eigenstates and
second
what we get depend on the specific state
psi in which our system is
so postulate 4 introduces the famous
probabilistic nature of quantum
mechanics
rather than telling us the precise
outcome of a measurement it tells us the
probability
associated with any given outcome
because of this postulate
in quantum mechanics it is impossible to
know the exact outcome of any given
measurement before you actually make the
measurement
all we can predict is the probability of
getting a particular outcome
so what does it actually mean that we
have a probability
associated with a given measurement
outcome if we have a system in state
psi and want to measure a it is in
general
impossible to predict for that one
measurement what we'll get
we have to actually measure a to find
out the answer
this is radically different to classical
mechanics where we can predict
the outcome of a measurement even before
we do it
instead what postulate 4 tells us
precisely
is the probability p here of a given
measurement outcome
to understand what this means imagine
that rather than having one system in
state psi
we have many exact copies of the system
in state psi
say n copies when we measure a for each
of these systems
we can in principle get any of the
possible eigenvalues as an outcome
so for example for the first system we
may get lambda 10
for the second one lambda 1 for the
third one lambda 99
for the fourth one we may get lambda 10
again and so on
let's say that we get eigenvalue lambda
n a total of p
n times then what postulate 4 is telling
us
is that when the number of copies n of
the system becomes very large
then the fraction of measurements that
give lambda n
which is pn over n approaches the
probability p
lambda n put another way quantum
mechanics tells us the exact rate
at which we will get a particular
outcome when we have an infinite number
of copies of the same exact system
if we just have one copy of the system
all we can know is the probability
of getting a particular outcome
the next thing i want to look at is how
the state psi of the system encodes the
possible outcomes of a measurement
remember that we can always write state
psi in a complete basis of our state
space
and that the eigen states u n over
hermitian operator like
a provide such a basis that means we can
write
psi in the u basis like this
and these expansion coefficients c which
we call the representation of psi
in the u basis are given by the
projection of psi
onto the u based states this means that
we can rewrite the probability p
of measuring eigenvalue lambda n
as also equal to absolute value of cn
squared
so what does this mean imagine our
system is in state psi and we want to
measure property a
then what we do is to write the state
psi in the basis of eigenstates of a
and the expansion coefficients cn tell
us the relative contribution of
eigenstate un
to state psi which in turn tell us how
likely it is to measure the associated
eigenvalue
lambda n an important
special case is what happens if the
state psi is an eigenstate of the
operator a that we're measuring
say um this corresponds to the expansion
coefficient cm equal to 1
while all other expansion coefficients
vanish in this particular case
we do know with absolute certainty what
the outcome of the measurement will be
the probability of getting lambda m is
the absolute value squared
of cm which is 1 so we will get lambda m
with probability
1. we can describe this whole process in
a more pictorial manner
let's draw a pair of axes
on the horizontal axis we place the
different eigenvalues of the operator
and here i am picking arbitrary values
for them
as we've discussed what these
eigenvalues are only depends on the
operator a
and it doesn't depend on the state of
our system
now let's consider our system in state
psi
we first expand the state in the basis
provided by the eigenstates of the
operator a
using the usual expression and the
expansion coefficients are given by the
bracket u psi
as always if we now place the
probability of getting a particular
eigenvalue as the vertical axis
then postulate 4 up here tells us that
at each eigenvalue we have a particular
height
given by the absolute value squared of
the c coefficients
for example for lambda 1 say we get this
of height c1 squared
and similarly for the rest of
eigenvalues
in this schematic i am just making up
the values but in a real situation we
will get them from the state
psi using this bracket this diagram is
showing what we call
a probability distribution the higher
the lines
the more likely we will measure that
particular eigenvalue
in view of this what does postulate 4
teach us about measurements
it tells us precisely what the heights
of these lines
are so it tells us precisely the
probability distribution of the
different outcomes
this means that we have a large number n
of exact copies of the system
the fraction of times that we will get
any given outcome approaches this
distribution
as n goes to infinity but for any
individual measurement
we cannot know beforehand what the
outcome will be
unlike classical physics in the quantum
world we cannot predict the precise
outcome of the measurement of a physical
quantity
instead what quantum mechanics tells us
is the precise probability distribution
of all possible outcomes of that
measurement in this video we discussed
the conceptual understanding behind
quantum measurements
but don't forget to check the companion
video that looks in more detail
at the mathematical subtleties
associated with them and as always if
you liked the video
please subscribe